meine These ist es dass der Staat
unmoralisch handelt wenn er auf der
einen Seite die Bevölkerung massiv
aufrufte sich impfen zu lassen und
andererseits wenn dadurch die Impfung im
Schäden passieren die Menschen im Regen
stehen gelassen werden ja genau also auf
jeden Fall um ein paar Zahlen zu nennen
dass paul Ehrlich Institut berichtet
davon dass allein im letzten Jahr eine
sechsstellige sechsstellige Zahl von
impfgeschädigten gemeldet worden sind
also es sind natürlich immer noch zum
Vergleich mit den gesamtgeimpften wenig
aber auf der anderen Seite keine zu
vernachlässigen Größenordnung wenn man
auf der anderen Seite wiederum sieht
dass die Versorgungsämter der
verschiedenen Bundesländer die darüber
zu entscheiden haben ob ein Impfschaden
anerkannt wird ihre Arbeit nicht machen
sogar in Berlin wo wir jetzt sind Null
anerkannte Impfschäden vorkommen und in
Hessen wo ich herkomme ebenfalls n
Menschen anerkannt worden sind mit ihm
stehen kann das nicht richtig sein die
Leute haben vertraut auf die Impfung auf
das was gesagt worden ist und wie bei
jedem Medikament auch bei einem
Impfstoff kann es zu nebenwirkend zu
schweren Nebenwirkungen kommen und wenn
das passiert ist muss man sie auch
großzügig entschädigen ja und das ist
nicht der Fall das ist mein Aufreger ja
was sind im Schäden es ist also nicht so
dass jede Befindlichkeitsstörung nach
einer Impfung darunter fällt nein die
Mandanten die ich in meiner anweisen
Praxis vertrete haben schwerste
Erkrankungen zum Beispiel Myokarditis
das ist ein Herzmuskelerkrankung
sinusvenenthrombosen Schlaganfälle
Autoimmunerkrankungen und die Reihe sich
noch
unermesslich fortsetzen es ist großes
Leid bei den Menschen die vollständig
aus ihrem Leben gerissen sind die ihre
Familie nicht mehr versorgen können die
auch ihren Beruf eben nicht mehr ausüben
können und es ist fraglich bei sehr
vielen ob sie überhaupt in ihr früheres
Leben werden zurückkehren können und den
Menschen das ist meine meine Forderung
muss ich mehr gekümmert werden wir unser
anweichen Praxis weil vom Staat nicht zu
erwarten ist Stellen
Schadenersatzansprüche an die
Impfstoffhersteller also moderner Astra
Zenica Johnson und Johnson und biontech
und was ich sagen kann die Gespräche die
ich führe sind durchaus sehr
erfolgversprechend für eine
außerirdische Einigung und da ist eben
auch eine Möglichkeit wenigstens eine
finanziellen Ausgleich zu bekommen im
übrigen wenn jemand anerkannt würde als
impfgeschädigter dann sind es
spektakuläre Summen im Monat von 156
Euro bis 811 Euro das ist schon die
höchst Entschädigung und da ist
natürlich bei die Impfstoffherstellern
wesentlich mehr zu holen aber trotzdem
und das ist meine Forderung der Staat
darf nicht wegblicken der Staat muss
sich um diese Menschen kümmern
Lauterbach spricht dauernd
irgendeinen wollte nicht zurück sagen
das habe ich doch gesagt aber über
Impfschäden hat er nicht ein Wort
verloren und das finde ich nicht richtig
ja ich finde noch wichtiger als sie
Entschädigungsfrage ist überhaupt dass
wir über diese Impfschäden reden die
wurden ja in den letzten Jahren einfach
bestritten als völlig unerheblich ab und
zu gibt es da mal einen Fall aber das
ist völlig unerheblich wir merken es ist
doch erheblich auch wenn das bezogen auf
die Gesamtzahl der Impfungen nicht
wahnsinnig viel sind aber wenn die
betroffenen Menschen wenn man die
zusammenzählt gibt es doch schon eher
klägliche Zahlen mit interessiert dabei
wie dieses Thema weggedrückt worden ist
wie so viele andere corona-kritische
Themen weggedrückt worden sind
beispielsweise die völlige Isolierung
von ungeimpften die sich ja täglich am
testen lassen müssen damit sie arbeiten
können aber die wurden ja trotzdem zur
Seite geschoben sie konnten nicht leben
mit einem Wort erstens machen sie sich
verdient dadurch dass sie über das Thema
reden und es an die Oberfläche ziehen
und den Menschen ein bisschen
Gerechtigkeit verschaffen hoffentlich
zweitens nicht der Meinung man sieht
auch daran es wäre jetzt höchste Zeit
die gesamte corona-politik in zwei
Jahren alles was es da gegeben hat das
Versagen des Staates für mich ist das
ziemlich durchgängig der Fall gewesen in
einem Untersuchungsausschuss des
Bundestages zu untersuchen auch die
Wirkung von Impfungen und die nicht
erfüllten Erwartungen von Impfungen also
dass man mal der Frage nachgeht mit mit
Wissenschaftlern die man hört und zwar
mit allen Wissenschaftlern und nicht nur
mit den Regierungsformen was da
eigentlich heute für ein Erkenntnisstand
da ist damit wir lernen für mögliche
künftige Wellen jedenfalls dass das
alles wird vor sich dahin sickert und
vergessen für vergessen das einfach dass
es mal anfing damit dass Herr Wieler der
Chef des RKI gesagt hat die Masken sind
völlig unerheblich die helfen gar nicht
und dann zum Schluss mussten wir sie
alle tragen also
impfgeschädigte Untersuchungsausschuss
das ist mein Beitrag würde ich mich
genauso anschließ da muss einiges auf
den Prüfstand das heißt jetzt nicht dass
wir den Impfgegnern das Wort reden
wollen das ist gar nicht mein Intuition
es gibt ja impfen
ja richtig durchgeimpft ja wie sich das
gehört nur es geht ja darum die Leute
sich vertrete die haben sich ja alle
impfen lassen ja sie sind dem Ruf des
Staates gefolgt waren sehr brav
sozusagen und jetzt erwarten Sie
wirklich dass ihnen auch geholfen wird
und da erleben Sie beim
Versorgungsämtern der Länder ja also
eine Ablehnungshaltung so können wir es
deutlich sagen ich meine wie kann es
sein bei so viel gemeldeten Impfschäden
dass es null anerkannte Fälle gibt es
wusste ich noch mal sagen in Berlin oder
in Hessen und in anderen Bundesländern
wirklich anerkannt zu werden als
impfgeschädigter oder ist es eigentlich
nicht also nicht möglich wenn sich die
Politik die ja letztendliche Vorgaben
macht für die Behörden ja nicht ändert
und dann ist dieser Weg kein gangbarer
Weg dann ist der Weg an die wieder
heranzugehen und dort im Vergleiche zu
schließen entweder Renten oder
Abfindungszahlungen der juristisch
bessere Weg trotzdem finde ich das nicht
richtigausschuss noch mal für die
Impfung also ob es eine ganzen
Untersuchungsausschuss braucht weiß ich
nicht aber was es braucht ist auf jeden
Fall ist auf jeden Fall mal eine Klärung
glaube ich der Datenlage weil was sie ja
sagen ist es wird in den Ländern zum
Teil sehr unterschiedlich gehandhabt ob
im Schäden anerkannt werden oder nicht
und da ist jetzt vor allem das
Bundesgesundheitsministerium glaube ich
auch an der Stelle gefordert wir
brauchen eine transparente Datenlage
nach meinem Kenntnisstand ist es ja
eigentlich rechtlich rechtlich so dass
Impfschäden gemeldet werden müssen den
örtlichen Gesundheitsämtern und dem paul
Ehrlich Institut anscheinend passiert
das aber nicht dementsprechend im Umfang
oder wird nicht entsprechend anerkannt
und da sitzt das der Minister gefordert
diesen Federn sind im Verhältnis zu
allen geimpften nicht viele aber es sind
welche die da sind und denen sich man
auch oder denen man sich von Sta anderen
Seite annehmen muss und da muss der
Minister jetzt liefern ich glaube die
der Weg führt über die Gerichte insofern
sind sie genau am richtigen Ort weil ich
nicht erkennen kann dass Paul das Paul
sage ich schon Karl Lauterbach mal in
der Lage wäre eine solche Geschichte
zuzugestehen es gibt Gott lob bei den
Medien langsam die Bereitschaft über
dieses Thema zu schreiben und zu reden
höchste Zeit weil eben der der
corona-druck im Moment nachlässt dann
erinnert man sich an die eigenen Fehler
die man gemacht hat worüber man was man
zur Seite gedrückt hat ich stelle das
beispielsweise beim rbb fest im rbb gibt
es eine Bereitschaft über das Thema zu
reden und
ein bisschen Selbstkritik wäre bei den
Medien angebracht denn das Thema ist
totgeschwiegen worden es gibt
beispielsweise wenn ich das richtig sehe
die Erkenntnis die sie in der
Wissenschaft durchsetzt dass jüngere
Männer bis 35 Jahre ganz besonders
anfällig sind für herzmuskelentzündungen
durch Impfungen das gibt dann so
Klassifizierungen die führen doch schon
mal weiter und damit muss man sich
glaube ich beschäftigen und deshalb noch
mal Danke das ist tun eine Überlegung
noch vielleicht warum das so
verschwiegen wird ja man denkt in den
höchsten politischen Kreisen wohl dass
wenn man das Thema so ein bisschen zur
Seite drückt dass man damit der
Impfkampagne nützt genau das Gegenteil
ist der Fall das Feld das im Schäden
gibt darf man doch nicht den Querdenkern
überlassen im Internet die darüber
wohlfeil berichten und der Staat tut
nichts ja das spielt ja auch bei anderen
Impfung Nebenwirkungen ja aber das fällt
ihnen den Rücken sozusagen ich bin genau
anderer Meinung die Impfkampagne würde
wesentlich erfolgreicher sein wenn
sowohl die vor als auch die Nachteile
offen und transparent kommuniziert als
letzte Frage zu dem Thema heute finden
Sie denn dass die Impfkampagne generell
gelungen ist in Deutschland also
generell finde ich jetzt etwas schwierig
zu sagen ich bin einer große
Befürworterin der Impfung ich glaube das
ist wirklich das ist was uns
wieder zurückbringt zu einem normalen
öffentlichen Leben ich sehe es aber auch
dass man
transparent über Vor- und Nachteile
sprechen muss das um einfach vertrauen
auch zu schaffen denn von den Vorteilen
gibt es ja wirklich extrem viele und
wenn wir die ganzen Zahlen der
longkowit-patienten aufrechnen der Leute
die durch die Erkrankung wirklich
langanhaltende Schäden haben ich habe
eine Kollegin die in meinem Alter ist
die nicht eigentlich nicht mehr
arbeitsfähig ist dadurch dass sie
relativ am Anfang Corona hatte ohne
geimpft zu sein also man kann ja die die
Fakten gegeneinander
ausrechnen und kann einfach transparent
aufklären und ich glaube das ist schon
wichtig und es ist ein Schritt weg von
so einer paternalistischen Haltung wir
haben jetzt entschieden was gut für euch
ist sondern wirklich zu zeigen ja das
sind das sind wirklich die Vorteile und
das könnt ihr haben und wir sind in der
Lage euch zu impfen und ihr könnt es
einfach in Anspruch nehmen ich meine das
ist ja erstmal ein tolles Angebot ich
habe das Vorteile zeigen aber auch sowas
nicht verschweigen und Datenlage
aufbessern